today's agenda we included preparation
for the European Council article 50 and
of course as always
Monsieur Bernier inform us on the state
of play and accurate development of the
negotiations linked with the withdraw
agreement and a transition period and we
discussed the draft of the guidance
future for future relationship for the
future relationship we the guidance the
draft of the guidance plays an ambitious
free-trade agreement at the core of the
future relationship zero tariffs and no
quarters are envisaged but this is not
only the our ambitious we are think that
future cooperation should also include
in areas such as foreign policy security
and defence aviation Fisheries research
innovation education culture etc Robin
Costa toda program important Pisco
recommendation Conrad appreciably grass
and presentation trickle Oh Jean they
blow the prose edda co the hot red pond
Oh Bravo D avec des V Davis on a popular
combination Edessa secures a governance
Allegra mafiosi yessiree situaion
caso de la langue de donde no sora
conserve our motto no no gasps McLaren a
resume whoo-hoo - tipo des in solution
backstop Donna Cordova trae el dinero
hajikko complete relay Osito and
parallel to total solution here
rated represent a low value means